[Music]
I'm gonna try and focus the talk on a
bit about you know what is possible when
people have create the environment to be
able to imagine an alternative society
and you know was I think the idea and
the spirit or perhaps philosophy of the
rajah revolution and I think it's it's
not it's not very it's not possible to
meaningfully understands the Roger of
revolution without understanding that it
does have quite a deep history you know
it didn't happen overnight no real
transformation of a society does ever
really happen overnight and especially
in the case of the Roger of Revolution
which is you know is now officially
called the Democratic Federation of
northern Syria but just for the sake of
making it easier for myself when I'm
talking I'm gonna call it ro Java but
that is not the official name of it
anymore and the reason behind that is
Roger ver literally means Western
Kurdish and the more the the revolution
expanded and therefore encompassed you
know divert more diverse groups of
people that's when the you know the
people decided that for it to be more
inclusive the name of the area shouldn't
be a Kurdish name and it should be
something that's more inclusive which is
why we have yet another acronym so the
history of the Kurdish people is
essentially the starting point of this
of this revolution in a way that the
Kurdish people have have existed and
lived in those lands for many many
centuries if not thousands of years and
especially in the last hundred years
aspect after the sykes-picot agreement
and the drawing of the borders of Turkey
Syria and Iraq the Kurdish people were
divided into four nation-states so that
was Turkey Iran Iraq Iraq Iraq and Syria
and so therefore within these
nation-states the Kurdish people
experienced many forms of oppression
suppression
particular forms of assimilation
policies were imposed on them and you
know not to mention the many massacres
and the genocide attempts against the
Kurdish people on in all four nation
states that they had been divided into
you know within Turkey there was an
official assimilation policy called the
turki fication process where you know
the then leaders and the presidents of
the Turkish Republic said there's no
such thing as Kurds they're just
Mountain Turks which means anyone who
claims to be Kurdish is a threat and a
risk to Turkishness so they deserve to
die and similar policies in Iraq and
Syria where the process of something
called the Arab belt so there were again
an Arab ization policy to Arab eyes the
cash populations of those areas were
imposed on the on the millions of
Kurdish people that lived and yet that's
important to recognize actually that in
that region there's 35 to 40 million
Kurdish people so they're hardly a
minority really and so there was so
within Syria which is what will be the
focus of this session the as a result of
the Arab ization process and like the
you know the Arab belt there were again
the Kurdish languages bands Kurdish
culture any sort of expression of you
know Kurdish existence really and also I
think and again I'm not I might be wrong
about the year by thinking it was at
some point in the sixties that a lot of
Kurdish people were stripped of their
citizenship in Syria so which meant they
it was very difficult for them to leave
the country they couldn't buy property
they couldn't it was like very difficult
for them to even buy a car so you know
it meant that they were you know the
attempt was to somehow make them more or
less completely and utterly reliant on
the Syrian Arab Republic and so kind of
you know
fast forward a little bit there was so
as many people know there was the Arab
Spring in 2011 where there were many
apple uprisings in the region and so in
2012 at the time when there were
uprisings in other parts of Syria the
Syrian President Assad must have thought
that he felt like he what must have
thought that he needed his his troops
more in the south of the country so he
literally withdrew them from the north
so the the Kurdish freedom movement that
had been preparing for something like
this for many years for for about 40
years saw this as you know a vacuum to
be able to put into practice what they
had the paradigm they had been putting
together for a very long time which then
at this time the autonomy was declared
of North in northern Syria in 2012 and
therefore the revolution as it's
progressing today were was put into
practice which meant that there were
communes you know the very ground level
of society the communes to the
neighborhood assemblies to the Canton's
and then obviously now to the Federation
level assemblies you know they they
started to build those and they while
they were doing this
there was autonomous women structures
that were being built and each what we
call general structure which would be
you know the general communes had a 40%
quota for women and there was a you
there had to be a co-chair system so one
man and one woman who would administrate
that level of society and therefore the
most the most important decisions for
society are made at the very ground
level now these these this paradigm and
this has roots not just within Syria but
also you know in the foundations of the
Kurdish freedom movement that were
founded within the current borders of
Turkey as well and I don't know if many
people have heard about Abdullah Ocalan
who is
essentially the thinker behind this
revolution it was his ideas that
inspired and motivated these people not
only to believe that they could
transform their own society but also you
know once the threat of Isis came that
they could also fight against Isis in
the name of direct democracy ecology and
gender equality and so the the
foundations of this movement and the
reason why I emphasize this is you know
sometimes we forget that you know some
things some things are not possible
overnight when we're trying to make
change wherever we are in the world and
I can't imagine anyone disagree in that
you know obviously we don't live in a
perfect world so there's many there's
there's a long way for us to go
everywhere we are and so these struggles
and especially the foundations of the
rajah revolution would not have been
possible the way it it would not have
been possible if they weren't those
foundations built so you know up to La
Jolla not only was he the thinker behind
there this this paradigm but also spent
15 years in Syria talking to the
communities and the society every day
and trying to understand them so that
Spiteri one of the biggest differences
between what's happening in northern
Syria right now are many other
revolutionary instances that in history
is that it's it's not a it's not a
vanguard as' movement or a revolution
that says okay we're here now and this
is the way we want you to live it's it's
built in a way that it's it's command
completely embedded within its community
and within its society and therefore
that's why the most ground level of
society the communes are the where all
the decisions for society get made and
so when I was there in April I just want
to speak a little bit about like our
trip and kind of like go through the
timeline because each stop I feel like
there's there's anecdotes that really
really display the spirit of
what's happening there so we arrived
there the purpose of the trip was mainly
to do research on the alternative
education system of Roger and the
alternative economy so the co-operative
economy that is being put into practice
there and so we first arrived to so you
land in Iraq and you cross over the
border and the first place you arrived
in is what they call the Jazeera
accountant and so that's the very that's
the very east of I guess like northern
Syria so the North East and so that was
one of the first places that this system
was put into practice and at the moment
it's kind of like the de facto capital
and this is where a lot of the women's
assemblies exist the youth assemblies
and also where they have something
called the internationalist commune of
rojava which is where a lot of
internationalist go and and have the
opportunity to take part in six week or
six month education sessions which then
they can come back to you know go back
to their respective countries or
respective movements and you know
organized with that experience and so we
spent some time there and it was
remarkable how you know it's you know
it's the Middle East it's that it's most
that where we were was mostly Kurdish
people but also a lot of Arab people
that we met as well and some of the
questions before I went that people
asked were you know the conflicts
between Arabs and Kurds you know because
unfortunately the region has been played
with sectarian conflicts for way too
long and I kind of expected to see that
a little bit myself and I kind of
questioned myself after when I realized
that that weren't the case as to why I
thought to expect that for motivates
talks and interviews subscribe today to
the Institute of Arts and ideas at IAI
TV
you